so Beyonce uh uh Beyonce gets paid 24
million dollars to perform one hour in
Dubai who and who who's paying who's
doing it I have no idea what it is it's
probably a royal family I mean 24
million bucks for one one hour so here's
a question yeah is it overpaid or
underpaid over one 100 but what is it if
it's in Saudi Arabia dude hold on she's
probably gonna overpaid 100 is she going
down is that the most anybody's ever
paid anybody anything in the world yeah
24 1 000 it's overpaid unless she's
throwing gold at people by the way okay
so Adam overpaid or under 24 million
controversial I actually think she's one
of the most overrated musicians there is
I constantly ask people who do you like
better Rihanna or Beyonce because
Rihanna makes hits Bang Yeah but Beyonce
has this what is it the B the honey the
B's Squad whatever the beehives yeah I
don't I don't know if it's like the
Destiny's Child the the Jay-Z the
Mystique sounds good yeah play the play
the yeah you know what I kind of agree
this is her right now
she's testing the sound that's the hotel
that's being done at her performance
24 million dollars for an hour okay so
overpaid underpaid I'm gonna say it's
underpaid
24 million for an hour yeah so first of
all let's give us the math let's do the
math so you're not paying 24 Like A guy
offered me to speak at an event uh
International right now I get paid 250
an hour to speak okay 250 000 someone oh
my God 250 000 and we turned it down not
because I'm worried about going to Iraq
but we just turned it down okay we
turned down 90 of speaking opportunities
in the states 200 000 and they say how
is your rate 200 000 an hour because
it's not an hour yeah you want me to go
to La I'm losing a full day you want me
to go there no it's 200 000 for a day
and a half I'm not doing this for 12 so
really two hundred thousand dollars I'm
in Wi-Fi which is Wi-Fi typically
doesn't work when you're 30 000 you know
feed in the air you get you can't get
the job done and so it ends up being 200
000 dollars for a day divided by 12
hours it's really only sixteen thousand
dollars an hour I can do a lot more than
sixteen thousand dollars an hour so
Beyonce is getting paid 24 million
dollars for an hour for one hour first
of all the private jet to go to Dubai
and come back you know how much that is
that's a that's a million and a half
holy [ __ ] you mean two million dollar
fee to go from oh yeah she has to pay it
I mean uh in gas and stuff yeah if you
go with if you go with a G6 fit whatever
you do you're spending a million dollars
to go to the of course what are you
talking about a million dollars bro if
you if for Christmas we went from here
to Aspen and back that's 150 000 wow if
you're going from here to Dubai 20 hours
Aspen is four hours so four yeah it's a
600 000 Bill and Pat because what you're
spending well it's a million dollar bill
and imagine what jet they're sending so
then who's going with her no the exactly
I've been spending two million dollars
so meaning that and then she has to go a
day in advance to prep she's there for
probably three or four days it's really
not 24 million dollars an hour it's 24
million dollars divided by 36 hours
she's really only getting paid eight
hundred thousand dollars an hour yeah
that's [ __ ] yeah that's by the way
if I was her agent that's how I would
sell it that's incredible
check what you're talking about good
dude oh he's talking about his
opportunity cost it's not just the one
out I'm gonna say first of all that's a
lot if I'm telling you I'm telling you
you want me to bring my talent everybody
wants for she does five million in Vegas
it's a one hour flight okay five million
right now if you want Beyonce to go to
perform in Vegas if she's available it's
5 million for an hour but it's a
one-hour flight wow to go to Dubai 24
million I think it was a low low uh they
lowball they got I think Dubai won
amazing well what's the famous story of
a it could have been a plumber could
have been lawyer whoever it is is
they're like oh we have a problem get
him in here and he comes in and he fixes
the problem in five minutes he's like
yeah there'll be a thousand bucks he's
like you charge a thousand bucks for
five minutes it's like you're not paying
me for the five minutes you're paying me
for like 30 years of experience that's
to know what the hell's going on here
because I can fix it is that what it is
because it's a true thing and the woman
said can I have that he goes twenty four
thousand dollars she's like but you just
you know he goes if you did that in two
seconds he goes yeah I know but it took
me 40 years
with a plumber again I don't know if
it's true but that would be the well I'm
just curious I mean it's not that much
curiosity but Dubai has how many billion
the money in Dubai is well are they
going to sell tickets to our performance
or is it oh yes and then they'll make
their money back oh yeah I can't you
know I do I do this podcast For What 100
Grand and that's yeah and that's but
that's my give to you and that's that's
because I love you thank you the whole
time the whole time because when they
offered you five you're like no no I
like him I don't even have a changing
room this is yeah so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
and click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]